that's what they want
that's what they pay for
what is a transformational line
it's a sentence with eye in it that you
then massage to go deeper
can we
have an example
yeah say something with eye in it okay
um
i've been really thinking about my life
okay so
about my life is what we call the
birthday cake get rid of that okay so
now you're left with i've been really
thinking okay okay now
what's the deeper truth
what's the the answer to the question
what is the story of my life and what is
the truth of who i am
the answer to that is i've been really
thinking
okay
so
have you grocked that
what is the story of your life and what
is the truth of who you are i've been
really thinking
sure have you got that i've been really
thinking okay now don't forget there's
another concept see there's a lot of
stuff that goes
to demonstrate this
it's called the other side of the same
coin and the other side of the same coin
is not the opposite it's the same thing
said from the other end
so if i say
i'm always late for work
the other side of the coin would be i'm
never early
if i say i take my time when i go to
work
the other side of the coin would be well
i never take my time when i go to work
the other side of the coin would be i
always give i never take i always give
same thing from the other side
so what is the other side of the coin
too
i've been really thinking
what's the other side of the same coin
i don't know
well let's look at the word thinking
what does thinking imply that you're not
doing i've been examining things what
i've been examining things no that's the
same idea okay what does it imply that
you're not doing
if you're always thinking what are you
not doing i'm not living i'm not living
so
um i've been thinking about something in
my life get rid of something about my
life that's birthday cake i've been
really thinking other side of the coin
is i've not been
really living
okay
okay okay so say those two lines
i've not been really living
no i've
i've been really thinking
i've not been really living
i've been really thinking i've not been
really living
and what's the deeper truth underneath
that
karen
trying to think the deeper truth that
you've not been living there's a deeper
truth
well we've been in a pandemic
what we've been in the pandemic
now you're talking about something
specific okay and you're not giving me
an eye it's got to be an eye state
i've been dealing with the pandemic
every day for the last year
so the fact that you've not been living
the deeper truth is not that it's a
pandemic it's about you
what's the deeper truth that you are not
really living
i haven't been going out anywhere okay i
haven't been going out that's good i'll
take that okay movie theaters but don't
think about the pandemic because then
then you're getting back to birthday
cakes okay okay i don't want you to do
birthday cakes it's the story of my life
and the truth of who i am not about a
pandemic
it's the truth of who you are the truth
of who you are is
i've been really thinking
i've not been really living
right what's the deeper truth
i'm confused
what's the deeper truth to the fact that
karen is confused i found out some
information
that my life wasn't what i had been told
it was
that again without i found that
information
i was told my life wasn't what it really
was
now get rid of i told myself and just
make the statement my life wasn't what
it really was
good what's the deeper truth to that
then who was i
don't ask a question okay it's gotta be
i
make a statement
i didn't i'm not who i thought i was i'm
not who i thought i was deeper truth
i'm confused
that was earlier we're going deeper well
um
i'm confused
i'm not really who i thought i was
what's the deeper truth
how do we really know who we are i don't
i don't ask a question
oh i don't know who i really am now
and the deeper truth to that you don't
know who you really are
hmm
good
that's where i'm stuck
i'm stuck i'm stuck okay
and one more
what's the deeper truth to that you are
stuck
in your life and the truth of who you
are is you are stuck
it's the deeper truth
that was it okay there you are
overwhelmed
no no just who okay you were you were
down here right right well you went whoo
that was right here okay that is where
you are now can you hold on to that
and write your story
in other words you massage the
transformation line which is an i
statement you take it deeper deeper
deeper deeper as the answer to the
question what is the story of my life
and the truth of who i am and you get
rid of the end of the sentence because
we're not talking about
the
the rest of the sentence
when you got to i am stuck
and then i said what's the deeper truth
you felt it before you said it
and that's why you went whoo
because now you were
down there i
you didn't even have to say the words
you got there
now can you hold on to that
and from that place
of who
feel it
start to tell a story
any story
doesn't matter if you start to tell the
story from that place karen
your writing will be will change
okay
so what story pops into your head about
you being stuck
um
you want the exact information
just some information that i wasn't told
about my past
my upbringing tell me about it
you know write it you're writing it i'm
right don't you just now you went well
you went up
stay down with who
yeah stay down there
it's still pretty fresh i found out
about it accidentally
wasn't really probably supposed to find
out
and i found out and it
made me you're you're you're telling me
okay i'm chatting
for you
when did it happen who
uh i wanna know when did that who
happened
maybe two months ago
tell me
tell me about it uh just
found out some information that was
shocking
and
really
didn't know anymore i i didn't know who
i was after i found that out
keep going
and uh
i was angry that i wasn't told the truth
what was the truth you were told
probably don't want to say it because it
involves family
and they could be listening
put yourself in danger
well i had to confront someone
yeah i had to confront somebody for
covering things up
and not keep being truthful okay this is
what people want will buy this is what
people will pay for they want that story
and they want the scene they want to
know what the person looked like they
want to know what the dialogue was they
want to know where you were what was the
lighting light what you know what did
the were there sounds
make a movie
of that scene
and and
as gert just said
be brave
be bold
and mighty forces will come to your aid
so when you massage your transformation
line and you keep going deeper and
deeper you're going to get to that
sentence where you're going to go
and then you start writing
in that voice don't go up
to the chit-chat voice
stay in that deep voice and write about
it
who was it where were you what was
happening etc now i know you don't want
to go into it here but that is what you
would do as a writer and that's what
people pay for
they don't care your smartness that's
not important they want the guts because
that's what they want
that's what they pay for
so you want them to buy your book
and look you look at all the books that
are bestsellers and that people have
cherished is because characters have
been in trouble
characters have had a conflict
characters had to discover things about
themselves that they didn't want to look
at something happened they you know it
that's what makes drama that's what
makes literature
clever tales are not going to sell
but the deep truth of your life
will register with everybody because
everyone will go
yeah that happened to me too not exactly
that way but
sort of
hey joe you got to read this
brenda you got to read this book you got
to read this book you got to read this
book
because it suddenly becomes
about human beings who are in conflict
and sometimes it has a happy ending
where the character
triumphs learns to deal with it and
sometimes it has a tragic ending where
the character
is unable to deal with it
right
you're feeling it right now aren't you
yeah
if you can write from that place karen
you will make art
do you understand that yeah about a
transformation line
now if you can get to that deep place
without the transformation line
great that's just a technique i came up
with
but if you
but if you stumble onto an i statement
about a birthday cake
when my brother came home i was hiding
the birthday cake you get rid of the
birthday cake and now you got i was
hiding
what is this truth what is the story of
your life and the truth of who you are i
was hiding not about a birthday cake
i was hiding in my life and then you
massage it and it takes you deeper look
how it brought you deeper we should have
the camera on you right now
glad i don't have mascara your eyes are
fillet full of tears and your heart is
your heart is in your throat yeah
now
right from that place don't go up stay
there and write
and the writing write like you talk
don't try to be a writer
just tell the story and it will be magic
and you practice it that's what i teach
people practice it and
at the end of the first class of the
first seven classes
that becomes an important tool for them
what do you think
yeah
maybe give it more time before you
worry about if it's something that's
now
i've got a line for you to say to me
okay all right say that felt like
therapy that felt like therapy
but it's not therapy it's about how to
write something that people will buy
if you tell your therapist the story
that you you're not able to tell now but
that you would and you would tell it to
your therapist
the therapist isn't gonna go
hmm
you know if you start with the image of
when you got in the car with your father
and then do the part with the mother
it'll be a lot better
that's not what therapy is about
my class is about making art right
writing something good so you might read
what you wrote and i would say wow that
was amazing but you know the part about
the father why don't you open with that
and then go to the thing about the
mother see because we are dealing with
this as a work of art i'm not responding
to you like a therapist i'm not a
therapist i'm not here to get you to you
know go through your feeling about being
stuck i'm here to use that as a conduit
to get you to write in the deep voice
because that voice is powerful and when
the reader hears it
when e f hutton talks
everybody listens
that deep voice
you could be on the beach
on a sunny afternoon and you're reading
a novel about a man in a prison wearing
an iron mask
the story will transport you the reader
to some place completely different and
every novel every story every poem
does that it's intimate
it connects to the reader you are
talking to the reader and nobody else
the reader feels like this is just for
me in a way you don't say it literally
but you say to the reader
look
i had to tell you about something that
happened to me
i thought i was fine but then i realized
and i got stuck and my life has not
moved at all now there are some things
i'm going to tell you that i'm not going
to tell anybody else i'm only telling
you in this book
and some of the people in this story
they don't know about it but you will
know about it dear reader because you
and i have this bond and i'm speaking
only to you
that's the illusion you create with art
so
yeah getting to the deep voice
might
make you feel emotionally
uh
concerned
but that's what it is to be an artist
an artist doesn't just create with the
mind the artist creates with their soul
with their being
and you have to
that's what you have to suffer
they don't care if the dancers heels are
bleeding they just want the dancer to
jump up in the air and stay there for a
long time and then come down they don't
care if it was hard for them to do it
they paid 150 for these seats
that's what they want to see
and that's what your reader wants from
you they want blood
and you give it to them
you give it to them and then your book
becomes a best seller and you buy an
island in the pacific and retire
[Laughter]
do you see what i'm what the point is
i'm making here
you know uh because your stories are
universal they're everybody's story
but you felt the power of it didn't you
i did yeah
i'm not sure i'm ready to tell it but
well in the class you would you'd write
it
and then
in the class you'd read it
and you'd be trembling and you'd be
you'd feel like you're in danger
and then after you finish reading it
everybody would be moved and you'll go
hmm
i survived
i i'm okay
i told my story but i'm okay and they
love the story okay
what else for lunch
you'll be ready
you